I just woke up unpacking I'm already
late as usual
I mean you could never expect me to
actually get to the airport on time
we're heading to Vegas for Matt's
birthday so if you're only going for a
few days like I'm probably not going to
need all of my camera gear and computers
and tech and everything else that I
usually travel with so this is my light
packing of course I have to have a few
options of colors from Apple watch
either H 2 terabyte solid-state drives
and this is just a backup drive title in
case I lose anything
USB C adapters to because somebody
always forgets one some glasses
this massive No Fee this is my favorite
Apple watch charger because you can just
plug in the lightning cable here every
possible cords that I'll need another
USB C charger so suppose my things
charged through USB i can use this to
get away with charging almost everything
that couple USB adapters extra nivel
battery always hard to find so many
batteries so charger this is the camera
that I'm using right now oh this is the
charger an extra battery sending a 6500
my wide-angle lens to clean the sensor
of my camera this little tripod
microphone because there's been so many
times that I've had to record audio on
the go and I didn't have a microphone
computer think that's everything now how
to patch this up and let's get the heck
out here
[Music]
and God all right
the adventure begins I'll eat your
favorite place who will be so excited
this is our last goodbye until until a
few days your message to Jenna and
Matt's I call Jenna meet me downstairs
let's go let's roll workout time you
guys time to go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
kinda by time I've got time to go left
Rd turn up turn up turn up ready to send
it yes
yep that that's something that's
something you did your best to make
these yours
is under all of this wood sir
[Music]
now we face baby penis coming
will it sold hi read it burn it like
it's all by slipping it out of my mind
when we get close with gonna slowly get
yourself a snack maggot give it to this
little call
lipid didn't like a long time Oh baby
don't stop oh you just made it now we're
going to give it some food maybe do a
little bit of gambling whatever happens
in Vegas is probably going to be on
Twitter Instagram or vlogs have even
snapchat what do you know
do you like be fun
I like pizza not first brothers I mean I
am sure hi welcome to the party I was
leaving you oh my god you went right oh
I was leaving for you on the wall how
could you drive you drove up in the in
the what car today
ooh fancy
marked it far away from everything else
luckily we go back you know it's
throwing up on it or everyone in the sky
sleep which is like an incredibly nice I
did it so I'm going to see what I'm
missing allow them to are out there high
five people who are very excited to be
in Islam good hotline blogging hey
everybody I love cameras I'm joining in
the fight wow it's really nice Wow look
at all of us with our appointment shoot
dinner just pretty greatly can we just
talk about the fact how many people are
blogging here yeah but who's not logging
in for today oh you know over there oh
you can save them and post them later
that's truly portable kamau thank you I
do that a lot of bloggers
well you're right next door to them
[Music]
ah well there we go yeah okay we stopped
it sorry
wait you know I don't know you know shy
no oh goody do you have it overlook of
the in and out of Bravo Wow look at it
yes I'm so sorry to spring event you
good you can do that I'm here and we're
heading to dinner now hello friends with
Nick coming oh okay are you did you win
any money today
come don't know hungry really Cubano Oh
if anybody update now I lost on the
automatic you know hold is there okay
where are we
[Music]
one year old please do a Vegas starting
off the front go
[Music]
[Applause]
happy birthday how do you feel a year
older hold on hold on I got you
how about the he's ordering one happy
birthday maybe I you're all very nice I
can ride the car now my car insurance
and other insurance policies will
slightly reduce my insurance didn't go
down all the night reporting crimes well
risk now I wish I was a brain I'm
carless and now I'm closer to 50 than I
was 2-0 birth I am wait I was at a more
dealer there daddy here eat like the one
thing I want right now
Jordan's not feeling so well for this
for me today we're going to talk call I
thought this was indoor and I
[Music]
I think I have a new hobby the other day
I was thinking the theme you need a new
hobby and today I think I found it I
think golf might be my new thing I like
mini bulk you would never go with me to
that mini - I hate minigolf
funny good I'm I'm good amigo and you're
better yeah you're doing that good the
max been actually vaulting like he's had
a golf trainer like crazy
he's really good okay to put them
through the contact matt has 401 point
Matt that's not well that is 401 well
Jeff took for my shots - oh you should
have for money maybe I don't know oh
yeah we're happy one
[Applause]
[Music]
I would like to add that Jeff took for
my shot do it horrible second place
really well then tell me how bad I am
please well time for dinner now I'm
super exciting our absolute favorite
place and we come to in Vegas called
lava it's Italian it's delicious
their food is amazing and the dessert
it's still good and the sparkle oh my
god are you beeping oh yeah we booked me
color picture you guys are all very nice
to me
[Music]
while we just had the best dinner ever
and now I need to go to bed I'm so
freaking tired at the best time in Vegas
I think I like golfing now it's my new
hobby
happy birthday Matt thank you I
appreciate it when are we going all
f---ing we can go off whenever whenever
you're in general ready I'm still ready
glass eye guy would get through gate 545
sorry but wow you're really strong just
need that's incredible I broke the door
open there was like a little like a
single of wet cement shove my foam in it
what Frank baby here I did it I'm gonna
probably we're gonna win our money back
well games that up winning it back as we
are I wish
and you lose all your money right before
you leave I need to make you feel you
know I'm not going to happen right just
waited up the painting anyways you know
how they do this in YouTube videos elect
milk I haven't
like that picture right there if you
look at it just like a corporal of color
on the photoshopping but the way they do
it is it's a like random colors around
Mars and walk and with it I'll let the
girl or boy I was like oh I can surprise
it I never realize it's actually scary
right here
well here's the picture of all the pills
by walk on the corner like oh my god and
I train here come on all these different
colors they said over there must be if
you want to call the line it's gonna go
birthday painted right there does he owe
my god it's so cool
Wow
[Music]
yes you know
and like a lot of a men thank you so I'm
making Craig try a drink very nice okay
this is a nice chai latte you told me to
get whatever I would get for him so we
got nobody likes it
Cheers it has the most fun that I've had
in Vegas in a really long time
hi guys my fun in Vegas see you later
it was great cool are you blogging where
you want anybody aboard oh good good bye
bye bye until it never rains in Vegas oh
this is a road and they plot it look at
that that's crazy
where the car on the way to here first
hell you know I'm a story from you guys
hotel later can you even
[Music]